really happened but this year there are
three nominees from the same picture and
they're all up first time right yeah it
must be a nervous bunch and let's not
talk about nerves okay
Academy promised that all we had to do
was to announce the names of the five
extraordinary players who have been
nominated and for the best performance
of an actor and a supporting role and
they are Eddie Albert's in the
Heartbreak Kid James Caan in The
Godfather Robert Duvall in The Godfather
Joel Grey in cabaret and Al Pacino and
The Godfather and the winner is John
Gray
don't let anybody tell you this isn't a
terrific thrill
there are so many people always and in
this case it's it's very much the same
firstly I'd like to thank Hal Prince who
started at all next Martin Baum
Manny Wolff and sigh fewer Bob Fosse
whose gift is enormous and helped me so
much
the other players among them Liza Michel
Marisa and especially Fred ebb and John
Kander who wrote me the best songs in
the world I thank you and I thank my
wife you're all loved thank you